Et si le coronavirus devenait une maladie saisonnière comme le rhume ou la grippe.
Et si tous les ans ce virus venait pendant l'hiver pour provoquer les dégâts économiques et humains que nous voyons aujourd'hui.
L'avenir du coronavirus reste un grand mystère.
Peut-il muter pour devenir encore plus dangereux ou au contraire disparaître à tout jamais c'est ce que nous allons voir aujourd'hui avec l'ami Mathart
Etudier les futurs possibles du virus et vous allez voir ça peut être effrayant.
En 2002 nous avons déjà connu le coronavirus.
Disons le il n'y a pas UN mais DES coronavirus.
C'est pas la première fois qu'il y a des infections avec ce virus. Ça commence dès les années 60 mais le début d'une épidémie
c'est en novembre 2002 avec le SARS-CoV. C'était pareil qu'aujourd'hui même folie médiatique
sauf qu'elle a pu être stoppée par des mesures d'isolement et de quarantaine. Mais c'est pas fini en juillet 2012 un nouveau cas de coronavirus
originaire du dromadaire fait son apparition au Qatar le MERS-CoV pour Middle East Respiratory Syndrome
celui là ne sera pas stoppé en même temps il est très faiblement contagieux. Le problème c'est que vous avez
38 % de chances de mourir si vous l'attrapper et comme on l'a vu ce n'est pas notre première rencontre avec le coronavirus.
Et dans mes recherches ce qui m'a effaré c'est qu'il n'existe
aucun traitement contre le SARS où le MERS. La seule chose qu'on peut réussir à faire c'est traiter les symptômes.
Sur le virus de 2020 même si le nom change c'est
80% le même virus que le SARS-CoV de 2002 c'est pour ça qu'on appelle le nouveau virus le SARS-CoV-2. Mais là vous me dites
pourquoi on parle de COVID19 ? Et bien le COVID19 c'est la maladie à ne pas confondre
avec le virus qui est le SARS-CoV-2. Comme le VIH et le virus qui provoque la maladie le SIDA.
On trouve ce coronavirus un peu partout dans les chauves-souris dans la fameuse soupe mais aussi et c'est la piste privilégiée aujourd'hui
celle du pangolin. Car oui le coronavirus est partout dans la nature
et à l'avenir si nous continuons à être en contact avec les animaux sauvages
ce genre de cas se reproduira.
Le coronavirus est il en train de muter pour devenir plus dangereux.
Mutation c'est un mot qui fait peur on imagine tout de suite "Resident Evil" et ses monstres qui partent dans tous les sens.
Lorsqu'un virus se réplique dans le corps dès fois il y à des erreurs et ces erreurs
sont une chance pour le virus parce qu'elles peuvent l'aider à être plus résistants, à devenir plus violents à mieux survivre.
Ces mutations sont extrêmement rares, si tu prends une personne les chances de voir émerger une mutation
dangereuse est proche de zéro. Mais maintenant si tu prends tes centaines de milliers de personnes
avec des millions de virus en eux là ça commence à devenir chaud et les mutations ont
commencé au brésil on a observé des virus avec des génomes très différent des
échantillons chinois. La souche S plus anciennes généré à Wuhan en Chine et la souche L
plus agressive qui est une mutation de la première. Une lutte darwinienne pour la survie qui a créé ce monstre.
70 % des infections sont aujourd'hui de cette souche.
Les mutations ça veut aussi dire des vaccins plus difficile à créer si le virus s'installe sur le long terme ça ça comme la grippe
Tous les ans, il faudra se faire vacciner contre la souche en cours.
Et plus le virus se propagera, plus il y aura des mutations et plus il sera difficile
d'agir médicalement. Sauf à limiter l'infection, on n'aura pas de vaccin miracle comme on l'a pour la fièvre jaune ou la rougeole.
Demain, toi qui ne te protège pas, qui ne te lave pas les mains, tu seras peut-être le futur porteurs de la mutation
qui détruira l'humanité.
Faut-il craindre ou espérer ?
Les vaccins contre la grippe existe,
pourtant seule la moitié des gens se vaccine et les résultats sont dramatiques entre deux et six millions de français touchés
pour à peu près dix mille morts chaque année... Oui
0,1% de mortalité s'est déjà des dizaines de milliers de vies. Eh bien le coronavirus en Italie ces
5% de mortalité.
Ça veut dire que si l'épidémie s'installe comme une grippe, ça serait cinq cent mille personnes mortes chaque année.
Donc non, le coronavirus n'est pas une simple grippe. Mais ce qui fait peur, c'est pas sa mortalité somme toute raisonnable,
c'est sa croissance exponentielle.
Regardez si un malade contamine dix personnes par jour, premier jour
11 malades
deuxième jour 121
au sixième jour on approche déjà des deux millions. Dans la réalité un infecté transmet en moyenne à 3 personnes.
C'est suffisant pour que dans quelques jours... le million d' infecté soit atteint. Le virus à en effet une particularité,
les symptômes met beaucoup de temps à arriver.
Chez certains il n'y en a même pas en fait. Là devant ton pc tu te sens bien mais peut-être que tu es
contagieux. Et si 80 % des gens n'auront qu'une petite grippe, 20% requiert une hospitalisation si l'épidémie était total
20% de 60 millions de français ça serait 10 millions de personnes.
Or en France la capacité des hôpitaux publics n'est que de 200 000 lits. Si le nombre de cas explose
il y aura un moment où il faudra choisir à qui on donnera l'oxygène restants. Il y aura un moment où les infirmières
surchargé
s'effondreront de fatigue. Il y aura un moment où les hôpitaux seront pleins. Le taux de mortalité alors va pas rester aussi bas.
Mais intéressons-nous à une statistique sa longévité.
Est ce que le coronavirus tiendra pendant l'été ?
Après tout, on tombe moins malades en été. Les virus n'aime de toute évidence pas les temps estivaux. Et ça a l'air d'être le cas.
COVID19 se limite principalement à l'hémisphère nord. Le virus se propage - moins sur un axe nord-sud que sur un axe est-ouest.
Parce qu'en ce moment, c'est l'été dans l'hémisphère sud. Et même s'il y a des cas ils ne connaissent pas la même
propagation. Mais ne soufflait pas trop vite
Si l'été arrive chez nous, dans l'autre hémisphère ça sera l'hiver et le virus ne va pas le gêner pour continuer son travail.
Ça pourrait finir en effet boomerang du sud vers le nord. Tous les six mois le virus reviendrais.
Heureusement la recherche s'active, le virus SARS-CoV-2 fait actuellement l'objet d'une recherche
intense et acharné. La France en lignes de front avec son célèbre institut pasteur
mais il y en a d'autres et partout dans le monde, on s'active.
Il suffit de se rendre sur le site PubMed pour se rendre compte de l'effervescence de la recherche autour du coronavirus.
Des dizaines d'essais cliniques sont en cours par exemple avec des molécules
antivirales mais aussi avec des patients précédemment affectés ou même des cobayes volontaires.
Tout se passera bien, oui, tout se passera bien si on est sérieux.
Arrêtez de vous moquer des gens un peu trop paranoïaque.
Car non, vous n'en faites pas trop si vous vous laver les mains ou si vous faites des checks avec les coudes.
Ce petit délire yolo c'est juste une grippe, je continue à vivre... il met en danger toute
l'humanité. La véritable menace n'est pas aujourd'hui
mais demain. Vous n'avez pas peur du coronavirus, c'est très bien pour vous. Maintenant...
...arrêter de tuer des gens. Car si vous survivrez sûrement au virus, pensez à vos proches, pensez à vos grands parents.
J'espère que vous allez appris des choses.
Likez, abonnez-vous à la chaîne avec la petite cloche. Du contenu scientifique de qualité avec toute cette merveilleuse team y en aura.
Merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis je vous dis à bientôt ciao !